we have some questions here that we like
to
answer um to make it clear to many
people who do not know the significance
of uh the two eids no doubt we have
which comes at the end of fasting the
month of
Ramadan and uh that Eid is a celebration
no doubt thank
thanking God thanking Allah for what he
has given us in terms of sustenance
Provisions food shelter and we in this
day
gather um to bring happiness to our
children our families and we eat a meal
together uh we visit family keep ties of
kinship and share gifts on this blessed
day of
um the second type ofid which the
Muslims celebrate which
is which is also known as the Festival
of
sacrifice so the significance of ad it
symbolizes uh the act of obedience and
submission to God's Will
exemplified by prophet Abraham PE be
upon
Him prophet Abraham was tested by Allah
with his own son
Prophet
is and instead of prophet Abraham peace
be upon Him sacrificing his own son
Allah
commanded after prophet Abraham had
passed the test of being sincere Allah
commanded that the actual Slaughter
would be of a ram
instead and so a ram a sheep or a goat
or even a cow or a camel is sacrif IED
on this day the day of Eid which is the
10th day of the uh month in the Islamic
calendar and that is performed yearly
once the
sacrifice is
done then it is distributed into three
parts one for family one for friends and
relatives and one for the needy and
poor so this act of Charity and sharing
reinforces the values of generosity
community and support for those less
fortunate so this
is a great event again for sharing
caring
loving um keeping ties of
kinship and also no doubt remembering
the sacrifice and sincerity of prophet
Abraham in fulfilling the Commandments
of Allah and this also coincides with
the completion of Hajj
because this day
ofid um most of the acts of worship done
on Hajj are done on the day ofid for the
pilgrims who have gone out for
Hajj so just as the pilgrims who have
gone out for Hajj have acts of worship
likewise the Muslims around the world
who who are not able to perform Hajj or
who are not able to perform Hajj they
also have a day of
um acts of worship which is also a day
of for them and day of Acts of worship
because they actually
sacrifice uh an animal and distributes
me to the
poor so this Focus this shows us that
these are acts which focus on charity
and community
building so this day a day of prayers of
sacrifice a day of distribution of meat
to the poor and needy and friends and
family a day where families get together
and they have a meal
together a day of Charity a day of
visiting family and
friends and most importantly bringing
happiness to one's children and family
on this day of likewise you'll find
there's extra supplications
extra
uh where one glorifies
Allah the
Creator Allah glorifies Allah
more
making and uh there's also reflection
upon
oneself um upon the story of prophet
Abraham and his son Prophet is the
reflection of
sacrifice and distribution
of Charity to the poor and needy keeping
the ties of kinship these are all good
actions and actions that are that bring
one closer to
Paradise once more uh these activities
that are performed on this day they help
Foster a sense of
spirituality
community and
compassion we live in a time where
people become less God-fearing
people have become less
spiritual and you'll also find people
become very
lonely in
communities and so this is this is a
beautiful time for all people to come
together and share their love and
their kindness in order to bring about a
better society and better community
building the 10th day day of which is
the day
of comes in those first 10 days of that
month whereby these days are considered
to be the best days of the
year and um they're considered to be
even better than the days of Ramadan
because this day these days you will
find uh great acts of worship not just
the Hajj pilgrimage but also you'll find
Muslims increasing in their charity
in their prayers in their fasts in their
supplications in their remembrance of
Allah and theid day comes on after the
ninth day of which is the day of where
Muslims believe that Allah descends to
the lowest heavens and he boasts to the
angels concerning those that have come
from afar to seek his forgiveness and
most of the people on this day the day
of the ninth day of the hij the day
before is the day of where Allah
forgives many people and uh removes them
from being punished in the Hellfire a
day of forgiveness Mercy
compassion and overlooking of faults